nato and ukraine have concluded two
weeks of military exercises in the black
sea
the sea breeze drills involved 5 000
troops plus
dozens of ships and aircraft the more
than 30 countries that took part aim to
demonstrate the strength of their
alliance to an
increasingly assertive russia dw
correspondent nick connolly has been on
board the uss
ross a destroyer that took part in the
maneuvers
he reports from the ukrainian port of
odessa
russian ships shadowing the uss ross and
its allied vessels at just a few
kilometers distance
here in the international waters of the
black sea
joint u.s ukrainian exercise is nothing
new but this year is far from normal
after russia's unprecedented troop build
up on ukraine's borders
[Laughter]
potential conflicts with russian forces
precisely what these sailors are
training for
is very definitely not something the u.s
navy wants to talk about
crew members scrupulously avoid talking
about russia even though much of their
time
spent monitoring russian activity around
them
i don't sense that this is any different
than any other exercise that we do
or that we've done in the past how far
away from the russian nearest russian
investment campus
right now about two to three miles what
we have seen
is russian fighter jets operating in
international airspace much in the same
way that we've seen sea breeze
participants
operating in international airspace a
russian jet making its presence felt
a reminder if anyone needed that the
united states insistence on freedom of
access to international waters
isn't an argument that cuts any ice in
moscow which views the black sea
as its backyard and has complained of
quote provocative muscle flexing
with 5 000 troops participating on land
and on sea
these u.s ukrainian lead exercises may
have been the biggest ever
but they're still easily dwarfed by
exercises russia holds in this part of
the world
involving tens of thousands of
participants
the unspoken message behind these war
games is clear that ukraine
won't be left alone with its
unpredictable neighbor russia
but what exactly happens when these
foreign ships return home
with nato membership ukraine no closer
to becoming a reality
and no formal security guarantees given
ukrainians still have many good reasons
to worry about their country's security